you know I was just out in the lobby
just a second ago during the commercial
break and a guy was asking me a question
about tipping and it just made me think
about I haven't reminded you guys in a
while there's a rule if you listen to
this show if you didn't know the rule
I'll tell you what it is if the pizza
guy when he comes to your door our pizza
gal comes to your door to deliver a
pizza you ask them how they're doing and
they say better than I deserve that's
code for they listen to this show
they're working that extra job to get
out of debt and so you are required to
give them an extra-large tip when you're
parking your car if the valet parking
your car if you ask them how you're
doing and they say better than I deserve
you have to give them an extra-large tip
because they're out there in the heat or
the cold or the rain parking your car
for you and they're doing that to get
out of debt that's code for I listen to
the Dave Ramsey show I'm in Financial
Peace University I've read the Total
Money Makeover book and I'm getting out
of debt I'm out here working my butt off
that's what that's code for and so we
all got a band together people we have
to stick together and some of you that
are doing a little better and you're out
there running around doing stuff like
that and you're ordering a pizza or
you're parking your car that means that
you're in a position to give a nice tip
which by the way let me just help you
with this some of you need to understand
that tipping doesn't say as much about
the server as it says about you you ever
carry one of those trays all right shut
up then they're heavy
and when I didn't take that job in now
listen if you go in there and you can't
afford to leave a tip you don't need to
go out the cheapskate and Christians are
the worst people servers don't want to
work on Sunday because cheapskate
Christians go out to eat and don't leave
a tip what kind of witnesses that
I mean you know leave a track so you
ought to be smacked somebody just some
your mother should smack you leave a
track about Jesus loves you and here's
how you meet God instead of leaving a
tip well that's more important than a
tip yeah it's more important than a tip
but you have no credibility because
you're a cheapskate you lost your
relationship with your server in the
process doofus unbelievable so here's a
rule leave a tip here's a better rule be
outrageously generous with your tips
outrageously generous now I don't even
have a choice I kind of don't like it
when I get lousy service get lousy
service out of the kitchen lousy service
out of the waiter waitress whatever the
server whatever it is and sometimes that
happens but I'm my choice my position I
don't end up on somebody's dadgum blog
if I don't leave a tip you know I don't
have a choice I have to tip you anyway
regardless but you know most the time I
don't run into that and if I do I'm not
even in position to gripe about it
because that'll be there Dave Ramsey
story that he was in the restaurant
griping and I'm not gonna be that guy
so I'll just grin and bear it and eat
some food that's not really good and hot
because you drugged but getting it out
of the kitchen you know or whatever and
I'll leave your tip anyway but you know
what you're not in that position most of
you and so leave a tip just you know be
kind and the other thing is is I'm a
well aware sometimes the kitchen screws
up the deal and the server but if the
food's cold that's not kitchens fault
that be the server left it on the window
there that's how it didn't get there
they shouldn't rocket science people so
but anyway it doesn't matter
leave a tip most of the time somebody's
in there working their butt off they can
carry you and you need to leave it to up
let me tell you where you don't leave a
tip and you should when you stay in the
hotel I'll leave a tip on the bed gotta
leave Oh
they've some money laying there say
thank you for cleaning my room that's
just what I mean
here's an idea what happens to you when
you're more open-handed with money when
you're more generous in your giving and
you're more generous in your tipping
what happens to you you become more
generous you know what happens to
generous people generous people smile
more generous people are the ones that
open a door generous people are kinder
they're generous and more than just
their money they're generous and how
they handle situations generous people
are more kind you know I catch myself
when I'm being mean it's usually when I
haven't been generous lately but I'm a
little more compassionate when I'm
generous you are too and here's an it
here's the weird thing the more generous
you are the more attractive you are
generous people are attractive not
because you think they're gonna give you
money that's not it but they're just
they're just nicer people you've been
around somebody that never gives
anything and is selfish every time you
see them coming what they wanna they
they want something they're not bringing
something to the party they're taking
something from the party
these are transactional people you ever
meet transactional people whether it's
in business whether it's at work whether
it's a church or there's just in your
personal life they all they talk about
is themselves and what they can get from
the interaction those aren't generous
people I'll guarantee you people that
are that selfish don't give and I'll
guarantee you people who give and who
are generous in their tipping are the
same people that are kind in
conversation and let you actually have
something they ask about you and your
kids you ever have a 10-minute
conversation with somebody and as you
walk away you go they learn zero about
me and we learned everything about
them that's called self stinking
centered hello that's not a generous
person that's a transactional person
it's a selfish person they're shallow
too and guess what's weird they don't
get ahead generous people have a
tendency to prosper why because they're
attractive generous people have a
tendency to get the promotion they're
attractive
now jerks get the promotion see you're
one of those other people when you say
something like that it reveals that
you're not a generous person you live in
a you live in a world where the glass is
half-empty instead of a world of
abundance generous people have a sense
of abundance they think there's enough
for everybody and then some and they're
not they're scraping around trying to
squeeze every dollar out of every deal
that doesn't mean they don't negotiate
tough and it doesn't mean they won't ask
for a bargain that's not what I'm
talking about
but there's a spirit about this isn't
there the spirit of generosity the
spirit of generosity necessitates that
you're less selfish that you're more
selfless and when you give it moves and
reforms and crushes and reforms your
heart into being less and less selfish
so the more you're giving the more
generous you become in every way and the
more attractive you become in every way
and the weird thing is is that
opportunities come your way and that
goes all the way back to did you leave a
tip
i laughter penny just to prove to them i
didn't forget him that doesn't say
anything about them that says everything
about you now his tipping and giving the
same thing no but it comes from the same
place in her spirit doesn't it
people growling and snatching and
pulling and selfish like a
kindergartener saying my toy my toy my
money oh brother
you miss the point of the whole money
thing when you think like that this is
the Dave Ramsey show